en france 14 millions de personnes ont
un poids trop élevé et certains sont
prêts à tout pour maigrir
on pense bien sûr aux produits allégés
mais après cinq ans de forte croissance
les ventes semblent se tasser
peut-être parce que ces produits qui
sont plus chers que les autres ne
tiennent pas forcément leurs promesses
c'est le dossier de ce journal préparé
par claudine gilbert et michel anglade
et les vacances pour marianne dans
quelques jours alors pour se débarrasser
des quelques kilos de trous accumulés
pendant l'hiver
cette étudiante parisienne a décidé de
faire la chasse aux calories brûlées
alors la compote de pommes sans sucre
ajouté
les bonbons sans sucre sous garde fous
ici et le chocolat sans sucre
voilà donc je vais te mange pas la place
on va perdre cinq kilos elle ici les
ferments de comme marianne les trois
quarts des français achètent au moins de
temps en temps des produits allégés en
grèce ou en sucre et il espère que ces
sodas ce aux produits laitiers aux
biscuits les aideront à garder la ligne
ou d'une personne vont se dire youpi les
biscuits sont allégées du coup je peux
en manger 10 alors qu'avant je mangeais
que trois des plus classiques
en fait comme ya marqué léger ça fait
maigrir non ces produits n'ont jamais
fait maigrir personnes
ils font parfois un peu moins grossir ne
vont pas maigrir 4 120 calories aux 100
g dans les biscuits allégés contre 480
calories pour les biscuits classique un
allègement très relatif mais c'est le
principe qui séduit le consommateur est
depuis dix ans les gars vous allez j'ai
vendu plus cher ne cesse de se
diversifier dans toutes les gammes de
produits il ya tout partout des produits
allégés alors qu'avant il y avait
seulement la fpp yaourts et les boissons
mais ça que par exemple la crème des
crèmes là on l'a trouvé pas à la légère
a vanté à prendre quand j'ai vu cette
année les compotes de pommes j'ai pas
trop fait attention et oui le chocolat
je pense que ça fait depuis peu de temps
que ça léger près de 4 millions de
foyers français préfèrent désormais la
version allégée des produits courants
pourtant même l'industrie
agroalimentaire reconnaît que les
allégés ne font pas maigrir qui ne pense
pas que quand on met un produit light
sur le marché
on dise que c'est un bruit qu'à faire
maigrir son maigrir n'y a pas 36
solutions il faut faire un régime
médical il faut manger moins il faut
faire du sport une activité et c'est pas
par des produits light que vous allez
maigrir mais ce que les fabricants
n'évoque pas c'est la présence de faux
sucre notamment dans les sodas light de
l'aspartame peut être bon pour le goût
mais pas pour le poids mais en fait il
ya quand même un piège d'un vaisseau
dallas par tom c'est que le goût sucré
en bouche le goût de la boisson sucrée
en bouche et interprété par l'organisme
comme de l'énergie qui va arriver
ce qui fait que le pancréas qui est un
organe digestif favori des l'insuline
uniquement par le goût sucré de la
boisson
même si c'est une boisson light et
l'insuline est une hormone qui dans le
corps empêche la combustion des graisses
et au contraire favoriser stockage
bresse les produits allégés ne rendront
pas marianne plus légère pour maigrir
elle devra surtout manger moins bouger
plus et remplacer les sodas light tout
simplement par de l'eau